all right john mark how are you yes well
where'd you go where are you from
originally um actually i was born in
sacramento
um i lived there for one year
moved to studio city for a year and then
was raised south of the boulevard in
sherman oaks california
um
and a very nice neighborhood
that uh
some of my neighbors were katherine bach
of dukes of hazard
so it was quite a eclectic um
upbringing you could say uh
school was uh
a lot of uh
actors at that time and their kids and a
lot of musicians so i went to school
with
all sons of so many different you know
actors and musicians um
through the years of
you know
schoolmates were like weasel zappa or
you know jake bucy gary busey-san you
know people like that
um so um it was uh
a time
i'd say uh
when i was probably um
eight years old my brother's six years
older than me
and uh
nine or so he started to get into uh
smoking pot and um
of course my friends and i were all
curious about it but we didn't know how
to you know and then my brother realized
this one day so he turned me on to some
very
very good pot and um
so then it was this one guy that lived
on our street he was the oldest his name
was john tapo and we thought like you
know my god this guy you know he moved
out from his house and moved into the
garage and made this he had this party
room it was crazy and to
get in there you had to
cut up the pot really fine and smoosh in
a two-hit ball and you had to clear that
whole thing in one hit to hang out there
so i was able to do that and um
they had to hose me off that night i was
so hallucinating
and but both my parents being from
greece um
they didn't know anything about drugs
they had no idea what pot was or
anything of anything was
so um
um i had met a friend of mine named russ
laffy and uh he was my best friend at
the time and not by 9 10 years old
and i remember one time when i was 10 he
uh called me up and he said hey
i found my mom's boyfriend's cocaine and
quality supply you know and i said
oh great i'll be right over so i tell my
brother like hey i'm going over to
russ's house to do a bunch of cocaine
and he's like
all right be safe that's all he said um
well
i get over there and russ pulls out this
bag that i mean must have been
a lot of cocaine i'd have to say
probably if i would to think about it i
would say at least an ounce looking back
um he goes i took 15 quaaludes so here
catch up with me so i took
nine
and um this is after school yeah what is
it but this is after school what age um
10 years old he was 11.
and bugs bunnies on you know cartoons
you're after school watching cartoons
and um
i'm making out these lines on the glass
table and i didn't know that you had to
chop the stuff you know so i'm making
out these
lines that are humongous and we're
starting these huge rocks you know and i
mean
next thing we know it's nighttime um i
don't know we end up in his sister's
room and he's like tunnel vision like a
million miles away and i got this line
i'm like russ russ russ russ do you want
the last line line line line line line
he's like no no no i'm okay my mom's boy
boy boy boyfriend's ho ho ho ho ho
and this the mom's boyfriend comes in
and he looks at us because he's looking
for a stash
and he didn't
say anything
we just left i guess
i don't know what happened all i know is
that we had walked five blocks to my
house
on ventura boulevard this must be at
probably six o'clock
seven o'clock get people coming home
from work and we're punching each other
throwing each other into
the windows of every store down ventura
boulevard
in sherman oaks
nobody goes here's a 10 and 11 year old
kid that looked out of their mind
we turned on my street and my friend
russ must have been walking like this it
was on quaaludes so much
and i was going dun dun
i thought i was running like a six
million dollar man so fast
my brother is at the end of the street
our house is towards the end and
he took one look and he said oh my
[ __ ] god
you know he had to get rid of the
neighbors so he tried locking us in our
garage which was downstairs our house we
had stairs that led up to this really
nice house in sherman oaks
and we got out of there
and um
so he
he was uh very athletic
um he used to ride his bike like 20
miles a day so he got on his 10 speed he
couldn't find us anywhere
we walked down ventura boulevard
punching each other throwing each other
into parked cars
from hazeltine and if anybody knows
ventura boulevard all the way to
coldwater canyon which is a very long
walk
and we get to a friend of his house and
um the babysitter of his friend comes
out and sees us and she probably flipped
a gourd i mean she probably went oh my
god
well my friend russ just went in to
withdraw went into he overdosed right
there he was throwing up he was going
into convulsions
so she called an ambulance for him
and she tried to get my number out of me
to call my mother
and
i couldn't say it and she's like
i i can sing it
so
i think i did something like
seven eight
and she's like seven eight i'm like
three
[Music]
one you know
about an hour i don't know how long it
took but i got it out 783-1568
my mom shows up
and she goes can you walk to the car and
i say sure i take one step forward and i
just fall straight back
hit the ground she
with the babysitter i guess puts me in
the car they drive me back to my house
and um
don't know how i made it upstairs i
guess my brother must have helped me um
my dad's home by this time he's a very
conservative man you could say extremely
conservative
but my brother goes i got john
and my parents said okay and they just
went
to the deck
and watched tv and didn't think a second
thought about it
they probably had no idea what was going
on
so my brother did not know what to do
with me
and um by that time i had been playing
guitar since i was seven so i was
very
into playing guitar and um so my brother
made me play jimi hendrix's purple haze
all night long and he said every time i
got this look in my face like this
devilish looker i was getting out there
he'd slap me as hard as he could just
slap
and keep playing purple haze so i kept
playing you know
dun dun
dun dun dun
[Laughter]
and
the next morning um
i got up to go to school and uh
i was still
that i think that entire week
out of my frigging mind um i don't i
can't remember anything of even going to
school or even how i got through that um
i have no clue so that was um
the first introduction to
i'd say
harder drugs um at 10 years old so
by that point um
i'd say that um
i was uh much more interested in
experimenting with other uh substances
of that point i wanted to try
acid i wanted to try you know this
because acid sounded cool to me you know
like
blue dragon like you're gonna see a blue
dragon or something i mean it's a kid's
mind you know
and um because i
was maybe a little hung out with a
six-year-old brother and all his friends
and my brother was a dealer at his high
school notre dame high school
so this is where he
got another light that would be great um
notre dame high school so um he was
selling pot to all his friends
and um
so
i um
basically
by the time i was
in high school i
my friend that that happened with oh
thank you very much
his mother
um she was doing a lot of cocaine
herself and uh
smoking cocaine became a big thing so
when we were
i'd say he was 15 i was 14. we would
take her bank card and clear her bank
out of all the money to buy coke
so she stopped that by trying to
maintain us on a half a gram day habit
but
we would freebase with her i would tell
my parents i'm gonna go sleep over at
russ's house
oh okay no problem and we go to russ's
house and his mom connie
would
cook the cocaine up and um we were
freebasing and this went on through all
through high school
and um we had a boy
we smoked a lot of cocaine i'd have to
say at that time so um i had quite a
habit uh going this is freebase not
crack no this is freebase unit free
basically before crack took off yeah
before crack took off um my dad um had
moved up in the executive world where
now he was working for uh running an
insurance company that he was president
of
where
he was uh
we were in the million dollar range of
family at that point
so my dad's
and wallet he'd put a above the
refrigerator at night and my mom would
put her purse there and each of them
would have probably about two thousand
three thousand dollars in there
just go and reach in there and i'd take
that money out and i'd go score
and
my dad would just go you know
you know to my mom oh helen you know i'm
short you know
can you go to the bank and pull me out
another five grand they didn't think
anything of it they didn't even notice
it going on like that so um
um
this went on through all the way through
art college where i was uh
just doing
massive amounts of that and
that soon led to um
one of the people i was buying it from
was heroin they decided to uh you know
turn me on to that and i thought
this drug made me ill when i first did
it i mean it's like rap poison you know
i snorted it i was throwing up it was
but i thought you know my guitar heroes
all did this and i thought like you know
well this is going to make you a better
player you know i mean jimmy page and
you know
keith richards and stuff i mean you know
there's got to be something behind it
the reason why they're doing this type
of stuff
so uh
then
turned on to
slowly uh
playing around with that for quite a few
years
um
[Music]
i got into a band when i was 18. i
formed a band and
we got the singer and she knew about
that
because she was signed
to xxx records with jane's addiction at
the time with the chili peppers in a
band called love dog
all-girl punk band that was very big i
played scream which was a very big club
in downtown l.a
they played big shows so
her boyfriend
auditioned for us
as a keyboard player
you know he ended up being a keyboard
player for the flowers and now it's with
the foo fighters
so um
she said
no heroin you know anybody on heroin so
i stopped for that point
and um
we got a record deal
that didn't go through
ended up playing more and more i played
with a few acts
then it all stopped and i started
working as a scenic artist
and
then
cocaine got replaced with crystal meth
i got turned on to that and that put
cocaine aside it made that seem like
nothing
um
speed
was
back then unbelievably good
and uh unbelievably strong and i mean
you do a little bit you're flying for
days and uh
i had a lot of work
i was
getting paid twenty thousand dollars for
murals i was doing
so i'd be up for two weeks working as
many jobs as i could and running around
and all of this um
and at 30 years old um my dad
finally got hit to what was going on
and he decided that at that point
he was going to get me clean
i seem to have screwed up my whole
career at that point because i had a
a job
um
doing these blue sky and cloud ceilings
in this big mansion in
beverly hills and
there was we were subcontracted with a
lot of other people and um
they just weren't paying me my second
payment
and um it got to be where it was a
lawsuit situation
so i went to my dad i said hey dad you
know
could you uh help me out with this um
and i thought you know this would be
great you can help me out with this and
uh
and i i had this you know this time this
heroin problem now i'm you know
i'm strung out so i thought
okay i'll tell my dad and uh you know
and maybe it's the right thing to do
well
it didn't turn out to be the um right
thing to do um i don't know many 31 year
olds that get grounded by their fathers
but i did
so
um
i went through uh
a horrible period of time
working different jobs
for fine art packing houses and trying
to
keep this heroin habit so i decided to
go to a methadone clinic
and um
they started me on a maintenance program
i had no idea what that meant at the
time
and uh you're supposed to to even get on
maintenance you're supposed to have
proof that you've done heroin or been on
methadone or something for a year
well i tried a detox program for one day
six months earlier
and they said we're just gonna slide on
that we're just gonna you know let you
go ahead and
get on this on the methadone maintenance
program how many milligrams you want to
start on i got
i don't know what should i start on
these we suggest 80.
um
i'll put it this way
five milligrams of methadone is
incredibly strong
80 milligrams
to get on methadone
the chances of
getting off of that is not you're going
to be on that for life
there is i mean it's so powerful it's
overpowers heroin it overpowered um
heroin couldn't even get me high anymore
i had um started a
xanax kalonapin soma addiction
because that would be the only thing
that would work with that
and for 15 years i was in that clinic
every morning going there between
five and seven for the hours they were
open to get my dose of methadone
and um
one time i i missed it
um at christmas time and i didn't have i
if you miss it for three days you have
to have a doctor see you to get
restarted on it again
and um
well it was christmas time he was out of
town i went nine days it was probably
the worst
withdrawal i think i i can't even
i blacked out most of it it's it's so
horrible it was uh um
unfathomable
well
my father ended up dying
of
cancer
2003 and um
at that point we got some life insurance
money of his
so um
i went to go do what they call a rapid
detox
at the weissman clinic
now
to do heroin it's a one-day event if
you're on methadone it's a three-day
event costs eighteen thousand dollars
and what they do is um they take you to
this hospital
they put you on a morphine drip the
minute you get in there
and then when you're ready to do the
rapid detox
they take you and they put you under
anesthesia they put a tube down your
throat straps you to a table and fill
your stomach full of naltrexone which is
um an anti-opiate
like if you use it makes you sick
so that all your withdrawals happen
that would happen over a year or two
years happen in six hours
so for six hours
um
supposedly they had five black eyes
holding me down i broke the straps i
mean
a mess all i know is i woke up in a tub
and
up to my
neck
and diarrhea just completely
and they gave me vitamins the whole week
they said you need to cleanse your
system because you know
you really need to cleanse and i mean i
had the runs all week i
thought i cleansed the system
i had no idea that you know this drug
backs you up quite a bit um
so this nurse comes out he cleansing me
up and this happens seven more times and
i'm like jesus christ this is you know
a lot and um
i am
feeling
everything like so sensitive that
it's like time to take a shower i'm like
shower great and shower they wheel me to
the shower and it's like
nails hitting me i was like getting a
shower of nails and um
then they took me outside in the sun and
uh that might as well has been like a
ray gun shooting me in the eyes i mean i
was
i was like get me out of the [ __ ] sun
if you can [ __ ] do this anything
and i get back to my room
and um
i am i
must have thought that it was a smart
thing to do to call
every friend's mother that i knew and
say that i was clean at three in the
morning
just seemed like a smart thing to do at
the time i think
um all i know is my brother my mom came
to pick me up my brother thought i lost
my mind
he thought that whatever process they
did that i was
crazy
and um
they told me to go you're as clean as
the day you're born by the way
there's not a trace of it in your
bones in your mirror and nowhere
you're as clean as
you can ever be and you just take this
naltrexone every day
you won't have any cravings and make
sure that
you did clean your house of all
heroin uh
anything of paraphernalia right
because if you come back you will have a
problem with that and i
thought i cleaned it well enough well i
came home and there must have been uh
some foil with some heroin on a straw
somewhere
i could smell that the minute i walked
in the door i started throwing up
put me instantly into withdrawals i was
like
mom get that out here
cleared that out
so i stayed clean for a short while and
then um
i'd say
after a year
or so um
i uh
i uh
kind of lacked on taking this naltrexone
and um
one day uh
i had stopped taking it long enough
where
like that
i needed to score heroin again
after not thinking about it for a year
and a half i mean
didn't have a craving in the world
didn't want it couldn't stand the smell
of it i mean maybe throw up but
i'd never touch it again
stop taking that and all of a sudden um
there was that
need to get some
so i had bought a 20 bag of heroin
went into my bathroom locked the door
put it on some foil
didn't even think i don't think i
finished taking that hit
and all i know is that my mom broke into
the bathroom
slapping me awake i was pulled into a
cold shower
it was like i mean that one
half a hit or whatever
was so strong that um it was like
must've been like you know
first time i've ever you know trying
something that strong
and of course uh that led to wanting to
do it again
so um
i ended up
doing that again and um
of course my father
thought helping me out of a good way was
doing that was telling all my uh
clients that i was on drugs
because uh
he never was a big fan of art or music
or anything like that the way he was
raised in greece was
it's another story for another day
so i got blacklisted
so i just became
as i told him i said well i'm going to
be the best heroin addict you've ever
met
and my father and i went you know
uh that was before he died but after he
died i just kept that going that
attitude and i
moved from smoking it to injecting it
and uh next thing i know
it's
almost 35 years later
that um
still to this day
i um
have a problem with it and i try um
many different ways to
get off and it is after 30 after you hit
30 years of doing this drug um
it uh
it creeps into you in ways that i i
can't explain it's um
it's
if it was easy for people then everybody
that would ever that ever got hooked on
it would be able to get off of it
and everybody's reasoning for getting on
that drug is
doesn't really matter but once you
venture into that
and whether you start off with doing
narcos or
oxycontins and um you can't get those
anymore from a doctor and you decide to
try it
and you think that i don't need to use a
needle i could smoke this and smoking it
is okay and
you don't realize that you're signing on
to
a lifestyle of
hell
that's the best way i can put it it's uh
it's an
awful experience because you uh
this is not something that you can just
use
occasionally
and say oh i'm fine you need this to
stay well
you don't get high anymore you just do
it to um
be normal
you do it so your nose doesn't run
so your eyes are not watering you're not
sneezing machine gun sneezes in front of
people and uh you know getting very sick
so you know um
i had to do you know four shots before i
came here so i could be
so my hand wouldn't be shaking
that would be smooth so i wouldn't be
like that
um just to be able to talk about it
interesting enough um
and i told my uh
girlfriend you know
make me some more you know because i
might need some just even talk about
this
and she had him ready for me but the
uber came i just said [ __ ] it you know
i'll just uh
i'll rough it
so
this is roughing it for me actually
right now
um you know my nose a little bit runny
and i'm a little bit you know
you know it would be uh at the point
when i get home i'll you know be running
to that for sure
how was i now
i'm 52 years old 52. and do you have any
hope of ever getting clean from is it
heroin or fentanyl though um i don't use
the fentanyl uh day stuff and i i have
testers that you get from the needle
exchange
to not do that
i have been in this this uh
world for so long that um
i have
been able to
um
work so many different angles i have
done so much
i kept a moral standard that i wouldn't
do certain things um i i don't believe
in stealing i won't steal from anybody
i'm not a thief i
hate thieves
a lot of people
that's what they are first and then they
do heroin second it seems to be their
big thing is to steal from somebody or
steal from some house or something i
uh
would uh more less uh get
got good connections at good prices
and would be the middleman between
people
you know
you want to get an ounce i can get it
for you for
you know six hundred dollars i could get
you know the best heroine you've ever
tried for
you know less than twenty five dollars a
gram you know or 19 a gram you cannot
beat that you know
just give me a little bit off the top
but
and um you know
now i'm on disability um
you know i uh
i'm able to afford uh an amount that
supplies me
healthily
at that so
to try to get off at this point
my girlfriend
i've been with her for four years
she was a heroin addict for
many many years
and with her life mate who died five
it's now six years ago
uh
his name was jimmy bain he was a bass
player for d.o
he never got off
david he died
while on tour on a boat
so she had gotten very sick and
she had copd very bad and
she ended up kicking in the hospital and
she said i never want to
feel that again so she's
hasn't touched it since so
she i get it i give it to her and she
gives me my allotted amount each day and
she is trying to wean me down
to a point where um
and at that point
we really are kind of playing it by ear
we don't know what to do really tell the
truth um
i am
not quite at the point where i want to
stop because
there are certain things at 52 in my
life that has not happened
i'm not particularly happy with uh
where
my life has gone and the things i've
done and what i've not experienced what
i could have
so
um
sometimes i just you know
want to just go into that
nice warm place where i don't have to
have any worries any problems
no stress of nothing
um
i have a singer i've worked with for a
long time
her name's morag and she uh
she's fantastic um
her story is a story that is her own and
i won't even get into that um but she's
very talented but she
will not
want me to be on that in any way she had
performed she says that she can notice
my plane
there's a tad off when i play
so if we're rehearsing i won't do it
when i'm with her so if i go to her
house for three days to play i will just
rock it i will go through whatever i
have to
to be able to write the songs we write
and uh you know play my parts the best i
can whether my nose is dripping all over
my guitar i don't care
because i do play better if i'm not on
it
and i do
paint better if i'm not on it
actually i do everything better if i'm
not on it if i'm on it my posture is
different my shoulders slouch in a
different way my
language is a little different my you
know if you know me well you'll just my
body movements
you know just
it's littlest things but you can pick up
on it you can see those things and um
it's obvious as day and i can see it in
anybody else i come across
i know immediately
if i meet somebody i know immediately if
they're using or not i can watch a
television show and just go
that person's been using for
15 years at least
i mean it's uh
and it's an epidemic that's um
so funded by our government
that
they don't want anybody to get out
heroin
it was a time when doctors could write
scripts
for you
of norcos or oxycontin
now this hurt the cartel greatly
and um
even though the cartel may bring a lot
of heroin over the border
96 of it comes from afghanistan
and it is funded by private armies
um with gucci keflar and their beards
and they got the fields there and
they're
for zinc copper and heroin that's the
main
thing coming out afghanistan that's why
the war is never stopping there
because that heroin is coming there and
it's basically pure
it's the strongest heroin probably is
ever this city has ever seen
they have sent put runners out in every
middle-class upper-class neighborhood
that
you call somebody and within 10 minutes
they're at your house delivering you
whatever you want
that's how easy it is
you can
just walk around and they will drive up
next to you and they can tell your
heroin act and say you know here's my
number call me
and i you know i'll bring it to you
that's how
crazy it is
so um
and these doctors writing these scripts
the cdc the
government has gotten down so hard on
them that they've uh
they've lost their licenses and have all
been um charged for
because the people of od parents have
charged you know got charges against
them and uh they've lost their licenses
and no longer can they write these
any doctor you go to you go to the
hospital and you break your arm
and you're in bad pain
they may give you some opiates but they
will not give you anything to take home
with
no way you do not
any hospital anywhere
and
after
35 years of using it
i have found myself
in
a lot of hospitals
shooting heroin
leads to abscesses
leads to
many type of infections that
i have
had
i got
surgeries
at one point
i got called from santa monica
ucla saying that i had
85 emergency room visits in one year
for abscesses to be lanced
and um
when i talk about an abscess being
allowed so talking about the size of
like a softball
on my arm i mean
it's you know i have gone into the
hospital
one time at 41. they gave me a 10 chance
of living i was in septic shock
and
that's somebody calling me on my phone
and i don't know how i made it through
um
a lot of faith
and a lot of belief in uh
that there's uh
a purpose for me and a reason
for me to be on this planet that i lived
it's the only way i can think that i got
through that situation
one time i was in the hospital the blood
infection poisoning that
they said we have no antibiotic that can
cure this infection i'm sorry you're
gonna be here till you die it could take
a week to take two years
i was there
in icu
temperature of
probably
i know they put me on ice i was
hallucinating i mean i was
i was on my deathbed there was no chance
i was coming out i was 34 years old
and i had
[Music]
taken over my dad's business at that
time as an insurance broker
i was a teacher an insurance broker and
uh
i had hired an employee who's armenian
and she um
went to this church
and uh it's called saint nichtarios the
saint of healing
there's a bone in armenia
that um supposedly is 2 000 years old
and it secretes
oil once a year and they mix it with
holy water
this church opened up and they had this
holy water and she brought it into me
she came in my room
i thought she was the devil
she was half purple and half
green in her face and she was holding my
dead cat who was alive
and the whole time she's doing the cross
on my wrist with the oil my forehead i
didn't know this
i thought she was uh
i was maddening you know like what the
what are you doing you know
she scared me i thought she was the
devil and i didn't realize that my fever
had reached a point where my blood was
boiling
the next morning i woke up
on the second floor
and
i was out of there
what i would really point out about this
is that it is not
glorious it is not um
anything that
whether it's you know to somebody who
has lots of money can afford it to
the your person out here on the street
that's suffering for it it's probably
the worst thing that can ever happen to
somebody and it's um
[Music]
it's not something to be proud of and uh
in no way i hope anything i said is
glorifies it in any way because it's not
a glorified
thing at all it's actually
probably
one of the worst things that can happen
to you in your life and
it
brings nothing but wreckage
and uh
and it'll tear up every
relationship
love you have
if you don't
you know eventually put this down and
i'm hoping that i will put this down and
at this point in time i'm not there yet
but um
i have faith that i will get there
and i really hope that i do reach that
point because i don't want to
my ending to be that
that be my legacy and that
the you know of all the talent i have
kicked out the door because i just
needed to have dope
so um
you know
uh you know it's
well you do it for two years or 25 it's
it takes its toll and um
you know
drugs seem like a fun thing but
alcohol drugs whatever you want to use
it's just not it's just not going to
take you anywhere
but down
you know and that's what um a lot of
people don't realize
and it's sad because i see a lot of
young people
jumping into that
because they haven't experienced
anything in life
they want to experience you know
something
uh you know and it's a saddest thing to
see somebody at 30 years old starting an
addiction like that and you just know
like going god i'm 52 you have no idea
what you just got yourself into you just
signed a deal with the devil
and that's what i consider it to be
pretty much
so
you know that's the moral of the story
of that
as best i can say
all right john thank you so much for
sharing your story
no problem super interesting thank you
very much you're welcome thank you
you